[Music]
on this Tuesday night firing back the
Diplomatic tit for tad after Canada
accused India of being behind a BC man's
murder it has uh far-reaching
consequences how Canada's allies are
reacting and what the sick Community
here is calling for the plea from
Ukraine's president to the UN and this
is clearly a genocide his warning that
if Russia wins the security of other
nations is at threat as inflation Soares
tenants struggle I think what people are
saying is enough is enough a fight to
stop rent from hitting the roof and
things are off the hook in this basement
okay got me the eco-friendly fish farm
in the middle of
Montreal global national with Donna frez
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the Revelation by prime
minister Justin Trudeau that Canada is
pursuing credible allegations that
agents from the Indian government may
have been involved in the killing of a
Canadian man that has opened up both a
serious diplomatic clash and demands for
more
clarity in India a small group of
protesters chanted down with Justin
Trudeau India's government calls the
allegation absurd it is expelling one of
Canada's top diplomats in that country
and today the Prime Minister tried to
lower the
temperature we are not uh looking
to
um provoke or escalate we are simply
laying out the facts as uh we understand
them we have complete coverage of this
explosive allegation and the reaction
tonight from Ottawa New York and British
Columbia we begin in Ottawa with Tera
isri teria Donna the allegations are so
serious they're reverberating in Canada
India and around the world the Indian
government vehemently denies it had
anything to do with the killing but it
has already retaliated in what is
becoming Canada's biggest diplomatic
dust up in Years
sir India moved swiftly summoning
Canada's High Commissioner and informing
him the Indian government is kicking out
a Canadian Diplomat the expulsion comes
less than 24 hours after Ottawa did the
same it is extremely serious and it has
uh far-reaching consequences and
international law and otherwise prime
minister Justin Trudeau revealed
publicly India may be behind the killing
of Canadian Citizen and sick leader
Hardeep Singh nider an allegation India
calls absurd the government of India
needs to take this matter with the
utmost seriousness Trudeau says there's
credible intelligence but did not say
what the opposition leader wants
specifics he didn't tell me any more in
private than he told Canadians in public
so we want to see more inform National
Security Experts believe it could take
years before hard evidence comes to
light but they say these accusations are
unprecedented it's extremely rare
for a democracy a democratic State like
India to uh be openly alleged by another
state to have engaged in an
extrajudicial killing Canada has the
world's largest sick diaspora India has
long accused Ottawa of providing shelter
to what it calls sick extremists who
want to separate from India The Strain
between both governments was on display
at this month's G20 in Delhi these are
long held frustrations that the Indians
have have voiced uh frankly for decades
given that volatility members of
Canada's sick Community are worried we
grew up uh with lot of these um these
concerns but there are questions about
how seriously Canadian intelligence
agencies took the threats against nider
who had expressed fear for his life
before he was shot dead there wasn't a
clear plan of protection that's
something that I'm deeply concerned
about Canada's allies are supportive and
concerned but a five eyes Source says
countries like the US are being more
cautious in their interpretation of the
information provided by Canada's
security agencies pointing out that the
intelligence suggests India may have
been behind the killing us intelligence
agencies have not gone as far as
publicly accusing India Donna right Tria
is re in Ottawa tonight thanks prime
minister Justin trudo is now in New York
for a meeting of the UN General Assembly
he won't run into India's prime minister
there Narendra Modi is not attending but
Trudeau is finding out how many of
Canada's allies are joining in on the
accusations about India our McKenzie
gray is in New York City McKenzie well
Don and Canadian allies have not gone
nearly as far as the Prime Minister
Australia probably going the furthest
saying saying they've raised this with
senior levels of the Indian government
but the UK and critically the Americans
have not gone that far saying they're in
conversations with Canadian allies but
not calling out India specifically on
this issue and I think it's best
underscored listening to Joe Biden's
speech at the UN today when he
referenced India in the Endo Pacific
we've elevated our quad partnership with
India Japan and Australia to deliver
concrete progress for the people of the
region on everything from vaccines to
Maritime security strong Partnerships
like Biden mentioned is something that
Canada was attempting to push with India
before as a part of their indopacific
strategy but Donna after yesterday's
bombshell that Justin Trudeau dropped
it's unlikely that will happen and
McKenzie can we expect that this issue
will be raised further while world
leaders are meeting at the UN well
candid certainly would like this to be
top of mind and that started last night
Donna with melan Jolie meeting with
forign Affairs counterparts from the G7
no word on how that meeting went but
despite this being a big issue there's
an even big ger narrative at play with
India and the West is trying to get
closer with India they're the most
populous country on Earth and they're
not align they're not with the West
they're not with China and Russia and
that's led to a real diplomatic dance
which is playing out here at the UN
trying to woo India and one of the
people who's trying to do that is
Vladimir zinsky the Ukrainian president
India's been neutral in the war and keev
would like Aid to be given to them and
they'd also like India to stop buying
Russian oil on the cheap from Moscow now
Narendra Modi is not going to be here at
the UN which means that Vladimir
zalinski can't make that appeal in
person it also means that Justin Trudeau
can't be criticized any further or have
any awkward moments like we saw at the
G20 with Mr Modi here in New York all
right Mackenzie gray at the UN in New
York thanks the prime minister's
accusation mirrors what many in British
Columbia's sick Community suspected
since the night niser was murdered back
in June now they're saying their
Community needs better protection they
want answers after a month-long murder
investigation hasn't resulted in any
arrests com carali is following
developments for us from sui BC tonight
KL Donna BC sick Community taking the
night to let the news sink in but now
the focus shifts on finding those who
are responsible for the
murder the sick Community attending
prayers Tuesday at Sur BC's Guru nanak
gurwara among those prayers are calls
for justice who are those corporates who
are those individuals
involved Monday night a memorial for
Hardeep Singh nider hours after the
Canadian government found what it called
credible allegations of a potential link
between niger's murder and Indian
government agents in attendance niger's
son still in shock from his father's
death 3 months ago he even called home
like 5 minutes before it happened you
know get dinner ready I'm coming home
he's really happy his family in the dark
on the progress of the investigation
when did come out I was surprised but it
kind of drove away a little bit of
anxiety that we were kind of feeling
that you know nothing's being done but
why would the Indian government
allegedly set a hit out on a plumber in
Canada in 2014 India's Prime Minister
narindra Modi issued an arrest warrant
for Niger calling him The Mastermind of
the kistan Tiger Force which the Indian
government considers a terrorist group
he was never convicted of any crimes in
2022 the cmp's National Security
division warned nider he was under
threat of assassination but other than
that there was no information given who
why how one year later the 45-year-old
would be shot to death outside of the
gwara where he served as president
Canada must immediately identify and
bring to Justice those individuals who
are involved in the targeted killing of
har sing ner no arrests have been made
in niger's killing RCMP only releasing
this blurry picture believed to be the
suspect's getaway vehicle I think the
government is trying to get our allies
to weigh in on this there may be a
little bit of a freeze being on the out
with India maybe a little less sharing
the sick Community here also pushing for
Canada and its allies to set up
sanctions against India part of that
pressure will come in the form of
protest at Indian Consulate offices in
Vancouver Toronto and Ottawa on Monday
Donna all right KL carali in sui BC
thanks a little later Eric Sorenson
looks at why some six want a separate
Homeland in India and why it's such a
flash point Ukrainian President Vladimir
zalinsky is set to visit Canada this
week his first official visit since
Russia launched its full-scale invasion
of Ukraine he's expected to travel to
Ottawa and Toronto but today he was
front and center at the UN General
Assembly in New York it was zin's first
in-person visit to the UN and he
delivered an impassioned speech warning
if Russia is allowed to win in Ukraine
other countries will be under threat
Jackson prco
reports far from the front lines
Vladimir zalinski mounted a oneman
offensive from his
Excellency zinski warning Ukraine's
defeat would bring dire consequences and
the goal of the present war against
Ukraine is to turn our
land our people our lives our resources
into a weapon against
you 19 months into the war Ukraine is at
a Crossroads in dire need of longer
range weapons and military hardware just
as Russia forges new alliances to
replenish its depleted Army the
Ukrainian Port zalinski is not only
asking UN members for more support he
wants countries to formally stand
against Russia when hat thre is
weaponized Against One Nation it never
stops there each
decade Russia starts a new war in many
ways zalinski is Ukraine's secret weapon
an unlikely leader turned charismatic
Diplomat his first in-person visit to
the UN is part of a push to convince
more Nations that his fight is also
theirs try to explain to a number of
countries who have been on the fense or
who have been hesitant to back Ukraine
why it's so important what's really
going on and why Ukraine needs and
deserves their help the US remains
Ukraine's biggest backer delivering tens
of billions of dollars in military aid
just like zalinski President Joe Biden
warned countries they cannot sit idly by
if we abandon the core principles of the
United States to appease an
aggressor can any member state in this
body feel confident that they are
protected but in Washington where
zalinski will travel Thursday Republican
lawmakers are increasingly skeptical of
the price tag of us support is zinsky
elected to congress is he our president
I don't think I have to commit anything
I have questions for where's the
accountability and the money we already
spit polls show a majority of Americans
are cooling on support for Ukraine
knowing time may not be on his side
zalinski faces added urgency to find a
path to
Victory Jackson prco Global News
Washington the civilian death toll is
rising rapidly across ukra ukine another
nine people were killed in Russian
attacks today this drone strike far from
the front lines in the western city of
Lviv ignited several warehouses killing
one person and destroying humanitarian
Aid at least eight other people were
killed in attacks across Eastern and
Southern Ukraine Ukraine's Air Force
says it intercepted 27 of 30 drones
overnight tough times for tenants coming
up how some are struggling to keep a
roof over their
heads
for the second straight month the cost
of living in Canada went up fueling
concerns and other interest rate heke
could be coming Canada's inflation rate
Rose to 4% in August largely driven by
an increase in gas prices that's more
than many economists were expecting and
as Mike Jay reports the cost of renting
or owning a home in Canada's already
tight housing market also Rose
significantly it should have been
obvious to anyone with a car an extended
return to high gas prices would spur a
rise in inflation when gas goes up so
too does transportation and production
costs but when economists began looking
through the latest inflation numbers
something else stuck out you know we saw
another big upward move in rents and
mortgage interest costs and just more
broadly almost anything related to
shelter was uh was a little bit higher
than expected in fact average rent in
the country outpaced inflation by going
up 6.5% % but that's just the average
tenants of two downtown Toronto
apartment buildings say they've seen
rent increase notices of as much as
25% that in turn LED 300 tenants to
start a rent strike now in its fourth
month there a no power like the power of
the people and the tenants say they've
tried to negotiate with Toronto mayor
Olivia Chow even offering to mediate a
settlement but they say the landlord
which didn't respond to inquiries from
Global News has so far refused used
instead issuing roughly 60 eviction
notices however their fight is getting a
lot of attention and they're Fielding
calls from across the country from other
tenant associations looking to do the
same thing I think what people are
saying is enough is enough with this we
didn't know very well where to go and
now we're seeing groups in Toronto and
in in other locations doing this so it
is something that people can start doing
as Grim as it appears for renters
homeowners are in the same boat with
mortgage interest costs up a staggering
30.9% year-over-year leading economists
to worry about the repercussions of
another hike in interest rates we
haven't seen uh you know a great deal of
for selling of of homes yet um but the
longer interest rates stay at these kind
of levels I think ultimately we will see
more strains uh develop in in in the
Years or the months ahead I should say
Canadians are feeling the financial
pinch it's just a question of how much
more they can take Mike drle Global News
Toronto
still ahead what's at the heart of the
six separatist movement ratcheting up
tensions between India and
Canada diplomatic relations between
India and Canada are at an all-time low
after allegations Agents from the Indian
government may be behind the murder of a
sick leader in BC but calls for a
separate sick Homeland date back decades
SS are a religious minority in India and
and the push for an independent state
has long been a flasho for violence Eric
Sorenson explains how that complicated
history led to the moment we're in
today it marked the end of British rule
but the partition of India displaced
millions of Hindus Muslims and the
smaller community of sixs who became
refugees in their own land up to a
million died in all some 10 million
people were uprooted from their homes
India home from the Hindu majority
Pakistan created for Muslims but Punjab
overlapping the new border left six
without the independent state they
wanted over decades sick nationalists
called for Independence in 1984 there
were protests and riots in Punjab Indian
forces attacked the golden temple at
amzar killing hundreds of what India
said were heavily armed militants it was
an outrage for six we are now at war
with India in October India's prime
minister in Gandhi was assassinated by
her sick bodyguards in retaliation the
sick Community was brutalized thousands
were killed Canada had a growing sick
Community few were seen as militant but
in 1985 an Air India jetliner from
Canada was destroyed by a bomb over the
Atlantic Ocean 329 people killed the
worst terrorist attack in Canadian
history only Indigent sing rayat was
convicted but a sick militant group for
Kalani separatism was
implicated
today some six in Canada continue to
call for an independent kistan wanting
to claim a large area over Northern
India but in the last decade India's
Prime Minister nahendra Modi has become
a powerful leader promoting Hindu
nationalism and cracking down on siik
separatism the leaders of India um see
the kistan movement as a violent
separatist terrorist movement and they
are very uh worried about it potentially
being funded by by forces in Pakistan
neish Bose says many in the sick
militant movement live outside India
there is freedom in this country for
separatist sentiments but the Indian
government believes Canada is not
rooting out what it views as criminals
in this country India also claims that
in Canada the Canadian authorities have
not done enough to um curtail and to
prosecute those who are a part of what
they consider to be Kalani uh terrorist
uh activity Canada has calleded out the
Modi government in the murder of hardip
Singh nider but that may have little
impact in India where modi's tough brand
of Hindu nationalism makes him very
popular
trud and makes Justin Trudeau the
villain Eric senson Global
News Something In The Water next how a
Montreal Farm is raising fish in the
[Music]
city you you wouldn't expect to find
fresh Arctic char in the middle of
Montreal but there is a thriving
population making a real Splash at an
urban fish farm it aims to produce about
30,000 kog of the cold water species a
year our Mike Armstrong went to see the
farm in the most unlikely of
places if you were given a 100 guesses
you likely wouldn't get close to what's
in this building's basement it's in the
middle of a Montreal Industrial Park in
was once a textile mill all right so we
are in the fish farm now well it is now
home to 11 fiberglass tanks and an
indeterminant number of fish they're
kind of hard to count okay got me
suffice to say a lot how many fish would
be in
here in that one there is about
11,000 yapak is the co-founder of upper
fish farm it grows one species Arctic
char it's native to Canada usually found
in freshwater lakes and rivers and
comfortable in groups considering the
cramped quarters that part was important
though pain says they thrive in the
space they have if they are scared they
can go at the bottom if they are angry
they go at the top uh they are not like
constrained to a small environment they
like protein Pake is a former mechanical
engineer who went back to school and
studied
aquaculture he and a partner started the
project with a proof of concept in a
garage and then expand it they po up
with so many fish waste is a concern
they've built a massive system that
removes solids from the tanks filters
the water and then adds oxygen it looks
complicated but it's basically a big
aquarium fair
enough now the whole project is meant to
be as eco-friendly as possible being in
an urban setting means they're close to
their customers they sometimes do
deliveries literally by bicycle but
being in a closed environment also means
there's no danger of disease or
parasites we don't use antibiotic we
don't use chemical we don't use hormone
for the for the fish the eggs for the
fish are bought from western Canada it
takes about 16 months for them to grow
to Market size the fish farm made its
first sales earlier this year the goal
is to get to about 30 tons annually and
eventually expand again mik carong
Global News Montreal
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna freezen tonight's here
Canada is the Sass river near Port alurn
British Colombia one of the many spots
along Canada's West Coast where the
shinook salmon run is happening it
attracts fishing enthusiasts from across
the country this woman is from Quebec
she got the catch of a lifetime thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye
e